hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
going to finish the division mode and
depending on how much time we have we'll
see what else we're gonna do but I
definitely want to try to get division
working properly so let me check the
live chat just say hi to everybody real
question about the programming language
we use it's gonna be JavaScript also
have a question or suggestion to get
fire code and enable ligatures for those
of you who don't know what that is
that's like a font for a code editor and
it does some cool things with like arrow
functions and equal signs and stuff like
that so I've actually have had fire code
installed before on a different computer
so on my work computer at my old job I
had that so it is pretty cool I may do
it again but probably not for this dream
because I want to get other stuff done
but definitely definitely looks cool so
I'm open to having that again for those
of you who are just joining I'll give
you a quick breakdown on how this goes
this is a live project I did not
rehearse any of this before so I will
most likely make mistakes and also some
of the stuff we do on the show a lot of
it I've never done before at all all
right so we're gonna try to figure it
out as we go along I usually try to set
a Pomodoro timer that means I'll do 25
minutes of coding take a five-minute
break and answer some questions in the
live shot if I have time at the end of
the livestream streams usually go about
an hour long if I have time at the end
I'll answer as many questions as I can
in a live chat so go ahead through the
questions in there any you can ask
whatever questions you want so don't
worry if if you think it's a noob
question or something like there's a lot
of beginners in here so any questions
are fine
feel free if you see a question in the
live chat that you can answer go ahead
and answer it I like to have a nice like
community that's helpful to each other
on the streams and I think that's it for
all the getting started stuff so let's
jump into it first things first I want
to give a shout out to to do for the
pull request that I just merged I'm not
going to go over this one because we did
in the last stream so if you're
interested check it out only thing that
changed was there was some division
logic in there that was removed because
it was I did a bad job of explaining
what I wanted to happen so yeah we
cleared that up in the last stream so
this just clears the input after a
submission so we'll see that now since
its merged in if you have the project
running locally make sure you update
update your fork so you get all these
new updates also Harshit submitted a
pull request where he migrated all of
our testing from puppeteer and mocha to
cyprus i checked out what changed in the
code but I haven't done anything with it
myself so we'll run our test suite just
to see like what it looks like but thank
you so much Harshit I'm excited to try
out Cyprus so I've heard good things
about it and those are the pull requests
for today the link to this repo is in
the description for the video if
anybody's interested please check it out
feel free to contribute code if you want
or list any issues we still have some
open issues here we're gonna do this one
today but this project is definitely a
great project for beginners to get in
your first pull request if you need help
doing that just let me know I'd be happy
to walk through it with anybody if you
submit a pull request and it's totally
wrong I'm not gonna be upset I want this
to be like a very pleasant experience
for anybody who's trying to get into
using get up alright so
let's go over what we want to happen
with division and then we'll we'll go
through if anybody is interested in what
this project actually is I recommend you
check out like video 1 & 2 of this
series so I don't even remember what
this is what number this is project 7 so
any videos you see this have P 7 and
then it's that's part of this project if
you go to like P 71 that would be the
first video I explain it more in there
but you'll catch on as we go along it's
a pretty simple app ok so here's what I
want since this is an app for little
kids who are just learning math at least
for the level 1 which I hope to add more
levels to this eventually level 1
division needs to be only numbers that
when you divide them will give you a
whole number so I have examples here so
examples of good problems to have would
be 9 divided by 3 4 divided by 2 but
we're never gonna have one that we
result in a decimal or fraction right 3
divided by 2
9 divided by 4 so that's the problem
we're gonna try to solve today is how do
we make sure that it's only numbers that
equal a whole number I could see the
easy answer is we can hard code it just
right off the top of my head however in
my mind I could see this game having
increasing levels of difficulty that
would include right now is only a single
digit it could include double digit
triple digit in that case hard coding
wouldn't be a great option at some point
you know we may want to include decimal
numbers in the game when it gets that
hard but at first I'd like to continue
to keep it whole numbers so we need to
keep that in mind so I'm gonna say hard
coding is not an option for this even
though
you know for for just our problem sets
for this show specifically it probably
would be the fastest solution let's go
to the code there we go all right first
things first and I recommend doing this
whenever you open up your code editor at
the beginning of the day always do a get
pool and that way if anything has
changed in the project you have the
latest changes
let's see use ref is not defined no
undefined
alright let's check out so we we have an
error here let's go I shouldn't say that
this is a it's not an error errors it's
kind of like re s lint rule since we
haven't actually run anything yet line
21 in our app J s file
and use ruff submit in foot he's fast
alright this alright let's check this
uh-oh
I should I can see harsh it already has
some ideas for how to how to implement
the division so hardship I'm gonna I'm
not gonna forget that I'm gonna read
that in just a second first I want to
see let's let's go back to github and
check out that pull request for this one
to see what changed files changed if you
haven't used github before this is so
useful to be able to go back and see
changes like this not you couldn't do it
other ways but this makes it so easy I
just that's what I thought okay so that
use ref is in addition here and and this
this might be
we might need to import use Ref
that's what I think yeah okay
Hart should already caught that yeah so
let's go ahead and just import use ref
then where's our code here alright so
you can see here so we're trying to use
to use ref here but we haven't imported
it okay so that's why we're getting that
error so use ref and now if we say that
it should be fine oops
and that looks like use it should be use
effects did I accidentally delete that
probably okay cool so let's check this
uh here's our app just to make sure
things are working and what should
happen now is I can put in a number in
here when I hit submit it clears and the
focus remains right so great and our I'm
just hitting answer now with that
awesome okay so let's move over to
division hey that actually works out for
cool
now I'm gonna read what harsh so harsh
it is a long time livestream contributor
here so harsh it is a really really
awesome software engineer so he's
suggesting that we make two random
numbers multiply them and make a problem
dividing them it will always be a whole
number and an easy problem okay yeah
that makes sense
yeah that'll work we do need to add for
level one at least we need to add a
check to make sure that the the product
of the multiplication is not two digits
right
yeah
okay also let's see what we have
currently for Division two that might be
a great place to start
and just say is is there anything we
could very easily do to modify what we
currently have
so everything all of our logic is I
believe in app dot J s right here's our
is it or do we move it now we've we
moved it
sorry I haven't even looked at this for
a week so I've been working on other
stuff I do want to let you all know once
we get the the logic done for level one
what I'd like to do is actually run this
in a simulator so probably like the iOS
simulator or oh no I'm on Windows
machine so maybe I'll try to run it on
my my Android either way like the next
step what I'd like to do is is actually
run this on on a mobile device at first
it'll just be like proof of concept that
we can run the same code on a mobile
device and on the web but I don't want
to get too far into this without at
least testing it on a mobile device that
way if we do have some code that won't
work on mobile then it'll be easier to
debug that with less code overall also
just remember I forgot to start my
Pomodoro timer so let's start that now
okay and I did not mean to start Spotify
all right
Oh harsh it also says don't forget to
try Cyprus okay we we will we will try
Cyprus okay
all right so I should saying like ok 2 x
2 is 4 now our problem be 2/4 ok Michael
Creole says if the answer modulo 1 is
not equal to 0 then get 2 new numbers ok
yeah that actually works as well because
then yet
okay I still need to figure out where
our division stuff is and scenario
reducers
yeah the logic got extracted out yeah
here it is
okay so we at one point we did have
everything in app DJ s and then we had a
bit of refactoring that happened in a
pull request and now we have some some
of the logic probably most of the logic
in this a producer dodge ass
okay so we're returning right now we're
just getting random numbers one through
nine
yes we're definitely gonna have to
switch that so I don't think there's
much we could do like with what we have
right now we're gonna have to have
something based on based more on what
mode we're on okay does that make sense
oh wow okay so yeah I got to keep up
with this chat over here dis are just
putting in some extra extra stuff let's
see thanks man
okay
[Music]
all right so let me I just need to go
over this file just for a second cuz I
haven't looked at this file for a while
it's probably been like a month since I
looked at this since we've just been
doing testing okay so alright here's our
random number generator which problem
set mode
enemy of enemy shake answer
okay right now we we do have
all right so we're getting the operator
from our okay so we're passing in that
state here and an action okay okay yeah
I should said you have a function for
random number use it then okay then
Michael's saying the logic is in check
answer yeah so I guess yes so we'll need
to check answer should still work as is
right because all we're doing in check
answer is just taking whatever our value
1 by value 2 is whatever our operator is
so that should be fine what we need to
change though is our new problem right
because what we really want is just to
make sure that we've given the user a
problem that we know will result in a
whole number so this is what we need to
to work on so currently right now this
though doesn't it doesn't know about
what mode we're in or care about what
mode we're in so we need to change that
the the mode that we're in is going to
matter in this case so let's see how
we're gonna do this so right now we're
returning
I guess we could just put an if
statement in here it mmm maybe you
switch I'm trying to make what else we
also want to make sure that subtraction
doesn't result in negative numbers so I
guess we'll have two cases where we'll
have we'll want more than just plain
random numbers so let's see
okay Michael Krause if the answer in
check answer is a decimal get a new
problem okay so Michael is suggesting
that we just go through spaces just keep
going through a loop of generating
random numbers and then checking the
answer until we get one that's a whole
number and then present that or negative
okay that's actually not a bad idea yet
how about that yeah so if we extract out
some of this into its own function which
shouldn't be that hard
yes so this could actually be its its
own function or at least this this part
and then that would let us problem keep
calling it all right let's do that first
then so let's take this and make its own
function so I guess we'll put it up here
right
do we really need to export this
function probably not cause what you're
gonna call this check answer and let's
give it let's see one about two
actually we could probably just do this
okay so this is just going to return so
if you're not familiar with arrow
functions so this is an arrow function
right so basically the the value then if
check answer is going to be equal to
whatever this is right it when you do an
arrow function like this all in one line
it automatically returns that so we
don't need to actually write return my
my Auto linting just put it on the next
line here but it's this should still
work okay so now that we have a check
answer down here what we could do is
because so I guess we need to get the
mode here in case alright so if the
types is new problem are we passing in
state action let's see what our state is
that we're passing in here just for a
second mode
okay so we should have access to mode I
don't remember what we called the
different modes uh wouldn't recall them
handle mode picker okay so that the mode
should be whatever the value is here so
you should be able to just get mode
division here so just like we're getting
state value state operator state we
should be able to get State thought mode
in our in our new problem okay so let's
say if States
actually I'm gonna do this now
I don't want to put it in that return
let's do it here so I can put one in
here stay mode equals division okay so
we're gonna wrap this in a if statement
here so we do want to at some point
return this right but not not exactly
like this right so what we want to do is
call check answer and we'll give check
answer oops
I don't want to do that I guess that's
fine actually let's do this there's
gonna be a little weird but let's say I
don't know if I want to name it the same
thing but well I guess we could well one
is going to equal say let's one equal
random number generator and I'm gonna do
the same thing with Val - okay so we're
gonna get two random numbers here and
then we're gonna pass those in one two
okay so a running check answer and let's
make that
but R is equal so res for like result
equal check answer so then we'll say if
res is greater than zero then we're
actually going to return something and
what we'll return is Val one Val - else
we're going to want to actually we're
going to rerun this whole thing so let's
grab this and say to grab all of this
put it up here and say division problem
and
okay else we're gonna actually run
division for and I didn't there we go
let me go down here now and say let's
get rid of all of this division problem
okay that's it a division problem
oops scared of this as well and this all
right so let me all right looks like I
had some commentary on what I was doing
let's see if this works first so here's
what I think will happen right so if
it's division if the mode is division
we're gonna call division problem right
division problem is gonna generate
random numbers and then it's gonna check
the answer okay so our check answer
function is here it's just gonna return
an answer if the answer whoops not
greater than here what am I thinking
I had subtraction on my mind okay
although it's this will work for
subtraction now too so we could just do
that so that's not what I need it needs
to be a whole number so what is that I
wonder if there's is there a way in
JavaScript to just check to see if
something's a whole number or okay
Michael so you just need to check okay
okay Mike was saying it's easier in the
check answer you already have the logic
do you need just check
[Music]
okay I've seen this now oh he's saying
check for that in subtraction at the
same time okay all right that makes
sense
let me fits in okay so rez where's my
mother there it is one and that should
equal
let me sing alright let's explain what
modulus is and I'm gonna explain it you
all let me know if I have it wrong it's
been a while since I used it modulus is
like the remainder so if we're doing a
division problem and we have a remainder
then that means it's not going to be a
whole number right so it should be zero
so like four divided by two is two
there's no remainder right but if we did
something like I don't know let's say
like four I'm sorry
see like 8 divided by 3 right so like 8
goes into 3 I'm sorry 3 goes into 8 two
times with a remainder of 2 right so our
remainder would be 2 so when we use this
percent sign which is our modulus
operator we're getting that that
remainder right so anyway that's it okay
okay yeah so Michelson yeah that's it
now
[Music]
okay alright I'm sorry where's okay so
we're right here so if we don't have a
remainder right then we'll return our
state will return that all just like we
were doing mio down here now if we do
have a remainder that means we need to
get more random numbers so we're gonna
call a division problem again right so
it's gonna call itself and that's what
is that that's called let's recursion
right
I believe that's what Leo a recursive
function right when it calls itself so
this could I mean hypothetically this
could just keep going and going but the
odds of that happening you're so small
right if we end up having a problem
where it just takes way too long to get
a random number then maybe we can come
up with a different solution but I think
this should be okay for now all right so
we have that and this shouldn't be that
hard to do the same thing with
subtraction but first let's make sure
it's actually working with division and
also the rest of it is just simply if
it's not a division problem we just fall
back on doing what we were doing before
which we know worked all right so let's
save that and go to or code okay so you
know about three minutes I'm gonna
answer some questions in the chat no
state is not defined uh uh all right so
we use state oh I see what's happening
we need to pass in let's pass in our
mode actually no where's our that's not
what we need we weren't using state
there where are we using state here and
why can we not get state
person states
and we're inside of this yeah I should
have access to state in there should I
not let me double-check that error to
make sure it's the one that I thought
lying six in line sixteen okay maybe
that's not the same thing okay so line
six oops
yep I need to get rid of state one about
two so we're passing in value one about
you two and we need to pass in the
operator as well since we don't have
access to state right there operator and
then line sixteen evident oh okay in
line sixteen we are okay so we're trying
to return the rest of this state let's
pass in state here then as well okay and
we'll just continue to pass in the same
state right here which we should have
access to from you
okay so then down here when we're
actually calling this we can call will
pass in state with our division problem
right that should give us access to all
of the state which means when we call
check answer here we should be able to
say State DOT operator because we have
access to all of State let's see if that
fixes it yeah let me know if that made
sense at all I can go over it again I
know I went through pretty fast yep
eval can be harmful expected break
statement before case snowfall through
okay those are not like critical errors
right now this we should still be able
to test this okay so we have division
6/1
sorry my mouse is there's like some bit
of I don't even know like there's sand
or something below my mouse is sure I
mean nuts right I don't need whoa ok
cannot reap repartee background-color
undefined
why would it give me that if I just
tried to submit nothing AB such is what
a weird air to get after Jay s look at
that what was that again 51
active scene background color
I don't even remember what theme I have
seems background-color division orange
this didn't happen before right
oh you know what's happening it's
something with the state I bet all right
let's see what we're doing with state
let's see if somebody
it looks like Harshit actually has a
pull request oh [ __ ] did you do this
well alright we'll have to check that
out but I what I think is happening
probably is something with the state
like we were so the problem is not in @j
assets it's up here
so when we try to return state here it
is not the same
chief
okay let's let me go to the chats I did
say I would go to the chat when the time
ran out and it actually was longer than
normal since I started the timer later
so I will stop take a five minute break
and then we'll check out harsh it's pull
requests and knowing harsh [ __ ] he
probably solved this in a better way
than I did so I'm excited to see how
this how he went about this let's see
it's actually cool though like I'm
assuming Harsha did in a different way
but it'll be cool to see two different
ways to do it although my way
technically didn't work because I messed
up something with state all right so I'm
going way up to the top of the chat I'm
just going to go down through and I see
there's a lot of hellos so I'm gonna say
hello to everybody and I'm gonna try to
just hit the questions for now
we had one question is what is he doing
lol uh-huh
I like big picture making a children's
math game with react native web just for
the stream I'm trying to figure out the
logic to give the user a single-digit
division problem that results in a whole
number okay I guess I saw its message
about trying Cyprus again so I gotta
remember to try Cyprus before we end the
show
at a question which compiler is this I'm
not sure what you mean by compiler if
you mean the like the IDE the code
editor it's Visual Studio code
so suppose how late is it for you it's
actually early so right now it is 8:14
a.m. so start this dream at 7:30 a.m.
Eastern Time
question should I learn react or Python
I mean they're used for totally
different things so it really depends on
what you what you want to do and if you
want to do more front-end stuff like
front-end web stuff learn react if you
want to stick like back-end stuff or
machine learning or something like that
then Python is probably better chris
says how Java or JavaScript again that
kind of depends on what you want to do
I'm gonna say JavaScript because it's
both the front end and a back end
language so it's a little more versatile
but there's a ton of jobs and a ton of
things to do with Java so you know you
you wouldn't be going wrong either way
it's just depends on what you want to do
chris says angular or react again that's
going to be a a preference thing like
what are you trying to accomplish what
do you know more of already or you know
what is your team more comfortable with
nick says hello I'm fairly new to
programming mechanical designer for 15
years but I want to get into some coding
for enterprise systems any
recommendations for languages or
starting point enterprise systems I mean
you'd have to look up maybe like exactly
what systems or what companies you want
to work for but enterprise systems from
my experience are more likely to be on
something like Java or.net you're you're
less likely to find like node apps
running for enterprise but I mean that's
starting to change a little bit but like
that's just been my limited experience
though so I mean I would you know do
more research on what systems are using
at the big companies
all right like Michael looks like maybe
has a comment on harsh it's PR so let's
go back to that I'm not gonna start
another Pomodoro timer because I'm have
to finish up the stream in a few minutes
so the last thing we're gonna do is just
check out this pull request and we may
have to leave this stream with kind of
unfinished we'll see all right so here's
y'all can see this I'm just going to
read it out quickly let's assume we have
two random numbers between 1 and 9 like
3 & 7 we're multiplying which is 3
multiplied by 7 equals 21 now 21 divided
by 7 or 21 divided by 3 will always be
an easy problem as 21 is a multiple of
both these numbers also it resets
problem now if you change a mode ok ok
actually I didn't realize we didn't
reset the problem before all right so
let's see what's actually happened this
is our reducer J s file okay all right
and Harsha did put in that use ref
because obviously I hadn't pushed any
changes up yet okay so if we have our
new problem here if the mode is division
we're getting our random numbers right
and then we're multiplying those two
random numbers we're saving that to Z
right and then we're returning Z and Y
so it would be like Z divided by Y okay
okay see boat operator I'll provide
and then returning
type types a new problem okay so this is
just doing a new problem okay so I like
that here's the thing though
we'll end up though with a number that's
greater than two digits here right so
this would actually this could
potentially work but we would have to
change the max number right on here so I
published an update refresh you can
limit it okay so it looks like there's
an update so let's refresh all right if
Z is greater than 30 returned a new
problem
okay so we could potentially just change
it here okay um all right what do you
think so
I guess everybody in in the stream now
let's let's do a comparison then all
right so in in this case for this would
work and then for each mode we would
just change this value so this I guess
we would end up saving I'm sorry for
each level so essentially this would
change for the level to increase like
the max amount that it could be right
[Music]
this is nice I like this
so this compared to I guess what we had
done here
where
we kind of have a we're actually like
checking the answers of our problems
Indian running through this until we get
one that works so let me know what you
all think I'm gonna take like 30 seconds
to see what y'all think and then I'm
gonna tell you what I think let's see
all right let me see what some of you
were saying
[Music]
okay so hard [ __ ] saying if you just
check so the issue that's raised in the
chat here is you know this would still
return something that's two digit
numbers arch is saying if you just check
to make sure Z is not greater return
reducers say it's a problem then we're
just gonna call new problem again
okay so either way it's just going to
keep looping right and it's gonna keep
going through that the benefit of this
one I would say is I mean I didn't test
it yet but the one that I did is
throwing an error right so I'm assuming
this one wouldn't so let's let's try
this out let's see if I'm gonna have
time oh I might not have time I got an I
got a meeting at 8:30 so that's who I am
I have seven minutes right now all right
let's see if we can if we can get this
in here really quickly it's check out
the division all right so I just
switched to another branch here so I
could save what I have okay and let's go
so China just go really fast
all right now we can do get get it fetch
our Oh what is it I always forget it
test a was locally I don't look Li fetch
I got full request get out of here I
don't want this big bucket I want github
there we go
very a git fetch origin pool okay so
it's our ID 14 who 14 and then almost
had it
head branch name okay H I'm gonna say H
division for Harshit cool yeah check out
H all right now let's try this up sorry
I didn't explain what I was doing more I
just I gotta go fast because I got a
meeting let's see all right so we get I
forget the changes let's change this
down to nine we want it not greater than
nine okay seven seven six six nine one
one like three 782 one looks good
you know what I'm just saying like
occasionally we get the same problem in
a row we may want to put logic in to say
like don't show the same problem twice
in a row so I'll have to remember to add
that maybe as an issue or if somebody
else wants to all right so
Harshit solution works I'm gonna go with
it because it works so I will be I guess
let's let's merge this in now you can
merge from the command line
so I could do that right now or I could
just
nevermind I'll just do it I gotta go I
got to go to my meeting so I have to
stop
basically what I'm gonna do though at
some point is I'm gonna merge this pull
request in so we're gonna use what
Harshit did I believe it accomplishes
the same thing without errors in less
code which is always good
thank you harsh it and then I'm gonna
try to remember to put in an issue to
say we need to check and make sure we're
not giving the user the same problem
that they just answered okay our [ __ ]
says yeah that's not my fault yeah I'm
not saying it's your fault hard [ __ ]
that's just it wasn't part of the it
wasn't anything that we had thought of
yet anyway so and it happens with all
the other modes as well alright awesome
so I don't think I miss questions but if
I missed your question just put it in
the comments below this video or send it
to me on social media or something thank
you so much for hanging out with me this
morning I'm buying a house later today
so I don't know if I want to stream on
Friday or not somebody busy moving into
the new house Oh harsh it says Cypress
you Cypress though alright one last
thing before I go let's use Cypress
because so yarn e2e what
thank you Jason
oh I forgot to run got to install
Cypress always remember to run yarn when
you first do your get pool in the
morning I've said that a million times
on the stream and I forgot myself to do
it what time is it oh I've one minute
till my meeting come on
can one yarn
no not gonna be able to get it in I'm
waiting
so the the meeting hasn't started yet
why why is it taking so long
Harshit I might just have to wait I got
I gotta go I know my meeting alright so
I may just have to wait if anybody
doesn't want to wait to see Cyprus go
ahead fork this repo clone it and you
can run it on your own the command is
the same as it was before you are an e
to e for some reason it's not working
for me right now what a terrible time to
not work hard says download in chromium
I thought you had I thought I would have
had it too because I was using puppets
here anyway yeah next time I will
definitely try out Cyprus and we'll do
that the first thing so I don't run out
of time or forget anyway thank y'all for
watching and hopefully I'll see you back
here next time
until then have a great day a great
great couple of days great week